[Music]
when i first started in the wig business
the hair alone could be up to 175
dollars an ounce
let's just say there was more money in
here than heroin
my stock of hair right now is probably
worth over a million dollars
[Music]
my name is nicholas piazza and i'm a wig
maker hair stylist wig designer i
started doing wigs almost from the
beginning of my career
this is my 50th year actually
these are some
covers that i'd done for some beauty
magazine i used two pounds of hair to
create this style i worked for the
kenneth beauty salon which was at that
time world renowned all the celebrities
all the movie stars including people
like jacqueline onassis and marilyn
monroe were clients
there i opened my own salon on the upper
east side i was there from 1985 until
2010 and i moved into the cello and i'm
in today gloria won did you wash this
wig no i didn't
okay let me cut it and then wash it
so it takes about five or six weeks to
make a wig the job of crocheting the
hair is called ventilating the
ventilating needles come in different
sizes
so if we're doing very fine work they'll
use a needle that only takes one or two
hairs in each knot and if we're using a
heavy wig we might have a needle that
takes up to 10 hairs in each knife
sometimes the more delicate wigs
actually take longer than the very thick
ones
at one time there was the synthetic wig
boom and everybody had a synthetic wave
and now people seem to be much more
interested in in the quality and they're
willing to spend the money for it my
custom wigs range from 38.50 up to 5 000
you know and i've made wigs for films
that i've had to charge more than that
for because i had to do them in a hurry
and paid through the nose to get it done
my clients are a variety of people it's
the kind of thing where you get a lot of
satisfaction when you have clients that
are undergoing medical treatments
sometimes it actually held them back
from getting their medical treatments if
they told that they were going to have
hair loss and then once they got the wig
and they saw that they looked as good or
in many cases even better than they
looked before they go into their
treatments with a lot better attitude
i don't know what sets me apart i'm i
care about what i do and also i know i'm
good at it and when you're good at
something you enjoy doing it
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i see color as a form of communication
i feel like it tells a story when i look
at colors like in a painting i think
automatically can i put that on a head
my name is daniel moon and i'm a hair
colorist
i first started getting into hair when i
was in the marine corps
i barbered myself and other friends i
was granted permission
to exit the marine corps to go to hair
school
being so restricted in the military i
think getting out of it there were no
limits restriction was enforced on me so
when it came to creating i kind of vow
that i'd never restrict myself from
doing something that felt like i wanted
to do and somehow came up with this
magic way of coloring hair
so freehand hair coloring is looking at
the head as a canvas
whether it's short hair or long hair
being able to
just paint on it as if it was a
sculpture
i find inspiration everywhere
i look to the art world
i look to the
magazine world i look in books i look
where people don't think about looking
when i'm choosing colors and designs i
imagine like a checkerboard
this purple's here this thread is here
can i connect this color to that color
i'm looking at it from every angle top
bottom left right and then just playing
with those different kind of shapes
i don't think about being different from
other hairstylists i create work that is
different for me it's different from my
last piece
i think people dye their hair to have
fun to create a persona that's fun to
live in
did some big color changes and had some
great collaborations with madonna
katy perry
nicole richie
and zoe kravitz the work that i create
is temporary and that is
a romantic thing because it fades away
hair grows out
i can spend three hours
six hours on a piece and then i can walk
out the door and it's never seen again i
like that it's an art form that washes
away
i like to just continue on creating and
just making something that i've never
seen before
[Music]
when i lived in queens
i went to the beauty parlor every two
weeks
i still do it here in this independent
living community
it's the same routine
this routine
is my life i have been used to it ever
since i came to america
look i'm 91 years old
and
i can't stop the aging process but i try
to remedy whatever i can
if you want to call it a beauty routine
say i don't i call it just taking care
of yourself
i do it as part of my living
i don't think i feel beautiful i feel
like
i'm thelma
[Music]
change is hard
change is hard at any age
but being a senior and leaving your home
and leaving familiar faces and starting
new routines important
so if they're in the habit of getting
their hair done on a friday at one
o'clock they still want friday at one
o'clock
i'm renee carpenido i'm the salon
coordinator and hair stylist at
riverwalk salon
i've been here for 14 years
and working in a residence like this it
does give you enjoyment being with them
it makes them feel good because that's
what they're supposed to be doing
they've been through it all doing their
hair making them pretty and making them
feel good you also
help them get through their day a little
easier
[Music]
i was born in 1927.
i was a teenager during the holocaust in
france
there were days when you couldn't take
the bath because there was nothing
but during the war i had
one lipstick and i remember it was
called rouge beze which means red
kiss lipstick made me feel beautiful
so it's important to me to keep myself
clean
and to keep myself
looking the best i can
we came to this country
after the war in 1947
i met my husband i was married 65 years
after my husband died i felt very lonely
and i was in terrible shape when i came
here
but the beauty salon is downstairs on
the lower floor morning i go to the
beauty parlor every two weeks
it's an intimate place
i talk to people you feel very good
going there
i know that i'll come out and i look
decent
two years ago my husband fell and died
i never thought that this would happen
to me
at the beginning i froze
and i said who am i
always dressed see this is the way my
family was we always dressed
this is my life today it cannot be
what it was
i have to maintain
who i am
i love clothes
my hair is the same as it was when i was
20
it's very simple and i don't want to
lose myself
so far i have not
[Music]
done has been here a little while good
morning
she's very sharp she's very into fashion
elma has her style she knows what she
likes i'm not too sure okay
and i do what she likes week after week
she shares a lot of stories and she goes
out often and you know she's just living
life and enjoying life
i feel like coming here gives me the
opportunity to have 95 grandmothers
it's a very comfortable place to be
they're getting older and their life is
getting a little harder so when you're
the one that makes their day better
that gives you so much more fulfillment
[Music]
[Music]
on the internet the other day i found an
animal that looks like something quite
familiar
they've tried to block the road but
outside of the road one share
turns out this fluffy looking
caterpillar that looks super soft is
actually
super poisonous
so i called dr wagner
he's an entomologist up at uconn my
specialty is lepidoptera which is the
study of butterflies and moths this
caterpillar it has a few names
well it's megalopygia percularis most
people call this animal the puss
caterpillar except in the south where
many people call it the asp these
caterpillars are distinct because
they're covered in what looks like long
soft hair
only mammals have true hair and then
what we find on insects are really
derived scales underneath those it's
where the poison spines are they're
maybe a little bit like a hypodermic
needle when you pet the caterpillar it's
quite a wallop i think of all the
caterpillars that sting the ass may have
the most painful and most toxic stain
that poison can cause headaches swelling
nausea blisters even difficulty
breathing and in case you were thinking
that these guys probably live deep in
some jungle you would be wrong they're
found mostly
south of the amazing dixon line
so here's a new adage to help you
remember
if it looks like trump's hair you better
beware